est-ce que c'est réaliste de dire en
2014 qu'il est possible de vivre en
français en louisiane
c'est sur ces les états unis là c'est en
aiguille minorités linguistiques vous
pour vous répondre tout franchement ce
n'est pas évident c'est un travail à
longue haleine nous sommes en train de
refaire notre monde morceaux à mort sous
la haie et on est en train de créer des
espaces francophones et il y a des
jeunes qui qui veulent parler en
français qui veulent vivre en français
qui veulent élever des enfants et leur
parler en français et ces jeunes
n'étaient pas traumatisé par le stigma
de l'américanisation à l'époque des
années 20 30 40 et 50
il y en a beaucoup qui ont échangé leur
langue pour la langue de l'employeur et
c'était l'anglais est là aujourd'hui on
dit que le français ça pouvait être
utile pour des endroits mais est ce
qu'on regarde ça comme c'est en voie de
disparaître
moi je dis non c'est en évolution ça va
être un autre francophonie savez
différents forcément forcément donc
c'est la francophonie des francos jeunes
par exemple ça c'est un élément très
important
et ces gens là ils sont motivés et ils
sont ils sont en contact avec disons le
centre de la francophonie des amériques
des amériques alors avec des
francophones à santiago coups bas comme
des francophones à saint boniface
alors ils vivent une francophonie global
universelle si on veut et ça c'est plus
court alors c'est plus une question de
deux par wyse
c'est une question de planètes et ces
gens là ces gens là ils pigent ils
comprennent ça
et puis à huy cdc des agents de
changement là ces jeunes oies et ça va
changer